Ciao mariners e benvenuti in questo nuovissimo video
Innanzitutto ci tenevo a scusarmi
tantissimissimissimo per la mia assenza qui su youtube
ho pubblicato poco in questi giorni perché ero malata morta per due settimane sul letto con l'influenza
Chi mi segue su instagram avrà visto le mie storie quindi ci sono le prove ragazzi non vi sto mentendo
ma chiaramente ora sono guarita quindi sono tornata sono attiva e
continuerò a...  inizierò a pubblicare video a
raffica
Detto questo partirei subito con il video che ovviamente come potete vedere parla di San Valentino
In particolare mi avete chiesto di raccontarvi
Degli episodi dei miei san valentino passati top e flop
Io ne ho selezionati per voi
2, 1 top e uno flop e partirei subito da quello top così vi lascio con
come al solito con questa nota di amarezza. Del san valentino flop così vi
Sentirete meno sole in questo san valentino che sicuramente andrà meglio di come è andato quello che vi racconterò
Allora il mio san valentino top in realtà e cioè è stato top per questo piccolo gesto era fatto questo ragazzo che nella sua semplicità
è stato molto molto
Apprezzato a per raccontarvi questo episodio, del mio San Valentino top vi
Devo anche raccontare insomma in quale situazione sentimentale mi trovavo ai tempi si parla di quando avevo più o meno 15 16 anni
Stavo con un ragazzo da qualche mese lui era ad un anno più grande
Di me e andavamo in scuole diverse quindi ci vedevamo solo nel weekend
in particolare
Ogni tanto cioè
Occasione proprio speciale andavamo a ballare il sabato sera in discoteca
Quindi quel sabato prima di San Valentino, San Valentino era accadeva come quest'anno in settimana di settimana
Quindi il sabato prima eravamo andati ballare soltanto noi due di solito andavamo in gruppo invece quella volta eravamo soltanto noi due quindi era ancora più emozionante
niente io mi ero tutta tirata
tacco, non
So 12/15 non mi ricordo comunque importante. Già. I tempi e nel momento in cui dopo un'ora di coda
varco la soglia della discoteca
Voi, non ci crederete aveva un piede dentro e l'altro fuori dalla discoteca mi, si spezza il tacco
Allora c'è io ancora oggi mi chiedo come diavolo è potuto accadere
Sta di  fatto che io entro nel panico perché comunque ero dentro la discoteca
c'è se uscivo dovevo rifare la coda
comunque uscivo devo ritrovare a casa perdevo un'ora era meglio che
Tornasse a casa direttamente e rimanesse lì oppure mi spezzavo anche l'altro tacco è iniziato a fare il tip tap
Sul cubo alla fine. La soluzione migliore era chiamare la mia amica
La mia migliore amica che era a casa non era uscita quella sera e chiedere questo favore della vita di portarmi. I tacchi
Lei ai tempi aveva il motorino quindi sono stata super fortunato perché arriva tutti col pony davanti alla discoteca con le scarpe
E mi. Ha salvato la vita quindi poi
La serata continuate è stato tutto carino era una delle prime sere che andavamo ballare soltanto noi
Due quindi era moto molto emozionante dopo quella serata
qualche giorno dopo era san valentino
Io ero a scuola in classe e mi arriva un messaggio allora hanno, anche questo video spiegare, non
so se esiste ancora però ai tempi di cui andavo a scuola c'era il leggo che era un giornalino gratuito che davano in metro o
sui
pullman che
lasciamolo lì i pacchi e ognuno si poteva prendere la sua copia
Gratuitamente io lo prendevo per leggere l'oroscopo di solito niente in classe ne giravano sempre due o tre
Mi scrive un messaggio il mio fidanzato dei tempi di scrive
Leggi vai sulla pagina numero non mi ricordo di del'lego
Io prendo il cubo sfoglio e c'era una pagina dedicata appunto al ai messaggi alle dediche
romantiche per san valentino
E lui mi aveva fatto questa dedica che niente di epocale però mi aveva fatto stra piacere aveva scritto tipo
L'altra sera eri bellissima
nonostante il tacco rotto
Buon san valentino amore ti voglio tanto bene
E il suo nome
È niente quello era un gesto semplice questo è l'esempio di un gesto semplice
Senza fare niente di epocale che però cioè fa la differenza perché comunque
Ai tempi soprattutto che eravamo ragazzini figure in classe con tutte le compagne dio cosa successe vai a vedere cioè erano tutte lì I
Lacrimoni perché lui aveva fatto questo gesto super carino e e niente io avevo pensato molto più di qualsiasi
Regalo, perché obiettivamente ai tempi cioè magari non ci potevamo neanche permettere a uno dei ragazzini e e quindi niente questo
ripensando che siamo agli anni passati è stato un episodio molto carino e quindi ci tenevo a raccontarvelo
passiamo il san valentino flop e per raccontarvi del San Valentino flop è meglio che
questo palloncino sparisca delle mie mani ma soprattutto dalle mie unghie perché non voleva che
raccontandovi e l'episodio dal nervoso insomma lo facessi esplodere
allora insomma il mio San Valentino flop
Riguarda insomma una storia che non era
stata insomma ufficializzata quindi io mi ero presa una cotta per questo ragazzo che si era lasciato da un po di mesi
e uscivamo uscivamo insieme
messaggini
Uscivamo, dalla sua compagnia li riportava a casa mi veniva prendere quindi arriva a san valentino io vado nel panico perché oddio cioè
Lo dobbiamo festeggiare o non lo dobbiamo festeggiare
Pathos ansia cosa decide di far marina gli organizza una cena romantica a casa per san valentino perché non
Si sa così mi sono svegliato ma facciamo così ha venduto lui accetta l'invito quindi come direbbe maria
Ha accettato l'invito quindi si è presentato all'appuntamento e già li era una buona cosa
Apro la porta e aveva questo mazzo di rose rosse
Casa ma allora è amore ma cioè
Sposiamoci scusa cosa stiamo aspettando entra io contentissimo per le rose ci mettiamo a tavola io ho cucinato e tutto bruciamo
tutto carino tutto perfetto musica romantica insomma stava andando tutto da dio
Arriva, il momento in cui insomma ci mettiamo a vedere la tv sul divano iniziamo a baciarci
E da che era una persona si è trasformata in un altra cioè, io non. Lo riconoscevo più
Quindi lo guardo e dico ma tutto bene è successo qualcosa
Non so mi puzzan le ascelle? Qual è il problema
Mi guarda e mi fa non ce la faccio
Che senso no perché io
Io penso ancora a lei
Cosa
stai scherzando
cioè
No, non
Ho capito fai scusa cosa stai pensando ancora lei chi alla tua ex vi siete lasciati da mesi
Sei qui con me sei venuto a cena da me. Ne guardo. Le rose ci sentiamo tutti I giorni
Perché stai pensando a lei why?? cosa perché non me. L'ha comunicato prima ma ci si tutta
Sta cosa
questo è quello che avrei dovuto dire
ma ero troppo preso mai della situazione quindi
invece dirgli questo
Lo consolato
Gli ha detto tranquillo non fa niente
va bene così
Il pro insomma lo tranquillizzava che poi di cosa che era venuto a sbattere a calci fuori da casa mia
Mi. Ha ringraziato e mi. Ha detto sei davvero una grande amica
Ecco io in quel momento non esisteva ancora la parola friendzone ma cioè
E quel momento ero la regina della friendzone cioè sono stata incoronata
E questo video si conclude così con questa immagine di una marina friendzonata e alla grande
E mi auguro vivamente che il vostro San Valentino non abbia niente a che vedere con il mio
San valentino super iper flop che vi. Ho appena raccontato
Come al solito se vi è piaciuto il video ricordatevi di lasciarmi un bel commentino di mettervi un bel like e se non avete ancora fatto
Iscrivetevi al canale e attivate la campanella vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre aggiornati
Su tutti nei nuovi video ma soprattutto seguitemi, su tutti gli altri social facebook musical.ly e instagram
Vi mando un bacione e ci vediamo al prossimo video di cosa parlerà
forse San Valentino?